amazon prime has finally got stargate
back in our screens
in america at least so i thought i would
take this opportunity to give you the
definitive timeline of the new series of
development and how we got from there to
here welcome to sidetrack your sci-fi tv
and movie channel
[Music]
so i've been talking about a new series
of stargate for
wow a year and we'd still not on our
screens i have been able to give you
lots of little scoops and a
behind-the-scenes view of what is going
on in the offices of mgm and amazon
so now it finally looks like amazon is
taking stargate seriously it's put sg-1
and atlantis back on our screens at very
least in the united states and uh i'm
told in europe and the uk very shortly
that i would take this opportunity to
give you the definitive timeline of how
the new series is being developed and
where we are right now so i have to
actually go back quite far back to 2015
for the start of this story because that
is when mgm first considered doing a
hard reboot kind of of the stargate
franchise
they were going to do a sequel to their
10th highest grossing movie of all time
the original stargate with james spader
and kurt russell now roland denmark and
dean devlin had both signed on to direct
produce right to this story james spade
and kurt russell had agreed to appear it
was completely green lit and going to
happen but then for some reason
i've never been able to quite find out
why it got scrapped now then we didn't
really hear anything official about
stargate in any new potential series
until the end of 2019
when brad wright officially announced
that he was writing a script a pilot
script for a new stargate series now i
am told that there was also an animated
series in the works now we've not really
heard a great deal about this since but
apparently the idea was at the time that
mgm did own an animation studio and they
thought this would be a really good
project something to
follow closely on the heels of the new
brad wright stargate series that would
you know work together with that this
news was dropped by giant freaking robot
something like a year after that and
that story became popular it was widely
dismissed as being nonsense but i am
told at the end of 2019 that was the
plan around this time
late 2019 into early 2020 there were
several rewrites of the script now brad
wright has talked about this himself how
there was a normal development process
he would basically send his work back
into mgm they would do little notes on
it and send it back and he would work on
it until he figured out a script that
worked for everybody
now i am actually told that amazon were
already involved in this project even
then that they were planning to be the
customer that basically mgm would put
stargate on amazon prime now that makes
complete sense because amazon prime and
mgm already had a reasonably close
working relationship at that point
amazon does have an mgm channel on it so
even then amazon prime were feeding
there
so even then amazon prime were feeding
back through mgm to brad and trying to
get him to go in a certain direction at
this point covid really hit us in the
backside and the entire planet basically
stopped for 12 months and so did
development of stargate franchise
nothing then happened for about 12
months oh by the way if you do like the
content please consider hitting the join
button and becoming a fully fledged side
tracker you can also go to side
dashtrack.com and pick marvelous
merchandise all these little things
really help the channel also if you're
new to the channel like subscribe hit
that bell notification and share the
video wherever the hell you want
but then in march 2021 something very
interesting did happen
steve wright became the new executive
producer in charge of scripted material
at mgm he then immediately scrapped the
idea of an animated series to go along
with brad rights he said
we don't have the resources to do that
and we wouldn't do a very good job the
mgm animation studio is crap it was
actually scrapped not long after i am
also told that this is around the first
time that real serious doubts about brad
wright's script began to surface
it was around this time that amazon did
more loudly start voicing its concerns
about what it was seeing and even some
people at mgm started to doubt that this
project of brads would have any real
weight moving forwards was it just a
coincidence that steve wright took his
position as the head and president of
mgm at the same time or was actually
steve wright that was voicing these
concerns most loudly in may 2021 amazon
bought mgm for 8.5 billion dollars now
they were not the only people interested
and actually in the run-up before this
apple were the most interested in buying
mgm at this time mgm was being told by
amazon that they were going to be
allowed to have free reign moving
forwards that they should start working
on some new projects and amazon planned
to give them full creative control and
amazon would only really act as a
customer that they wouldn't just come in
and slash everybody's jobs and take over
mgm was really convinced that they were
going to have full creative control so
it was around this time that mgm started
working on a second script for a new
stargaze show now we've never really
been able to quite figure out where this
script came from but talking to a lot of
different people i suspect and this is
only my opinion but i suspect this was
actually a dean devlin script that was
written back in 2017
now i don't think the intention was ever
to actually make this script happen i
think it was a
idea that they would sort of contrast
and compare the two scripts and the two
different visions for how stargate could
move forwards it was something that they
would then show to amazon later on and
that they would get a bit of an idea of
hopefully what everybody wanted to do
moving forwards
but they did continue to develop both
scripts doing initial artworks lots of
initial storyboarding they really
started to put me on the bones of the
existing scripts and really started to
get an idea of what the vision for both
would be so in march 2022
everything changed
the sale of mgm to amazon was finalized
and amazon to be fair
dropped the hammer michael deluca and
pamela abdi resigned in april of 2022
resigned over pushed is the big question
but they've never really spoken about
why they resigned that is because they
almost certainly contracted not to and
they would have almost certainly had to
sign some sort of contract when they got
their enormous payouts when they left
what i am told is though that they left
because it became very evident to mgm
that everything they'd been told in the
run-up to this point was a complete lie
that they were not going to be given
creative control that they were not
going to be allowed to continue to
operate as mgm and actually amazon were
coming in and they were taking over
everything and that even amazon
executives at this point said that mgm
would be absorbed into amazon pictures
they started using excuses like covid to
explain why these changes were happening
and why they were forced to take over
mgm rather than just allow it to carry
on operating as one of the biggest
studios of in history and then amazon
put all of mgm's projects into a kind of
stalling process
anything that wasn't in pre-production
was just frozen they all went into
review and small teams throughout amazon
studios began reviewing everything they
were looking at amazon were not at all
impressed with what they found now even
though mgm was being operated reasonably
well as a business it actually had been
profitable for a few years
creatively amazon were just
furious by what they found when they
started looking into it they found
ridiculous projects in development lots
of infighting apparently between
directors and producers etc and just a
complete mess
stargate was always intended to be one
of the big announcements they wanted to
pull off straight away there was always
going to be three big things that amazon
wanted to do as soon as they took over
mgm bond and that's been completely
screwed up stargate
and something from the intellectual
properties
some big new reboot or remake
none of those things have happened
simply because of what i'm telling you
that mgm was in such a bad way and
amazon had such a big job of absorbing
it into amazon prime that they just
simply couldn't allow them to continue
with any of the projects they had
planned
we actually did come
this close to brad wright's script
getting greenlit
mgm was planning to do it the second the
sale went through the second amazon gave
them the final go ahead mgm were gonna
push forward
i kept hearing rumors that brad wright's
script was not dead and buried and that
it was still possible
however becoming more and more unlikely
that it could still get made and again i
came on my channel and told you that
brad wright's project
was not going to happen this was only
then really confirmed by brad wright on
july 27th in a live video stream where
he actually said again that he never
thought his script was ever going to see
the light of day
so the voices that started a year and a
half ago
doubting brad wright's project did just
get louder and louder
but that is not the end of the story for
stargate because they are trying to
figure something out with this they are
trying to develop a new series but they
don't just want to create a series they
want to create a franchise because all
of the studios want everything to become
a franchise nowadays that's just the way
[ __ ] works nowadays
so as i told you a few weeks ago mark
ferguson hawk ostby the guys that um
created the expanse for amazon have been
approached to develop something for
stargate they're not necessarily being
asked to write a script for what i'm
being told instead they're being asked
to develop an outline of what the new
series would look like and how it could
form the part of a franchise for a new
series of series now from what i've been
told they're not actually being asked to
write a script or a pilot for stargate
instead they're being asked to develop
something a universe that fits with
canon for what we've already seen of
stargate sg1 sg and sga
but something that makes sense in a
larger picture so what they're really
being asked to do is create sort of like
a stargate bible this is something they
used to do for star trek all time star
trek the next generation famously had a
bible that gene roddenberry put together
it was something they dipped in and out
of throughout the seven seasons that is
what
hawke and mark are being asked to
produce now now that might lead into
them writing a pilot but at the moment
instead they're just trying to really
figure out how the hell they move
forward to stargate now on that point me
and matt this week are going to be doing
a couple of videos on how stargate could
come back whether it be a hard reboot or
a continuation of the story what are
fans going to be really excited about
and what are the challenges that maybe
might turn fans off
so look forward to those tuesday and
thursday this week on sidetrek
so don't forget guys that if you enjoy
the content please consider hitting the
join button and becoming a fully fledged
side tracker also if you are new to the
channel please like subscribe hit that
bell notification it really helps us out
and as always guys uh please stay safe
i'll see you next time
[Music]
you